first of all I want to begin by thanking
the founder of this feast mr. Daniel
Rose who was joining us for the day it's
really his generosity that makes
possible the the Henry Louis Gates Jr
lectureship and which is now in its
third iteration so thank you to mr. Rose
and thank you and welcome back to New
Haven I also want to thank mr. roses old
friend Henry Louis Gates Jr whose work
has inspired so many of us across the
disciplines and across the years since
he left Yale in the early 1980s it was
impossible for professor gates to be
here today and he he asked me to convey
his deep regrets to Daniel
Rose but also to our speaker and to all
of you as well and now it is my great
honor to introduce our speaker professor
Patricia Jay Williams currently the
James door professor of law at Columbia
University professor Williams took her
BA at Wellesley and her JD at Harvard
she first worked as a deputy city
attorney in Los Angeles and then as a
staff lawyer for the Western center on
law and poverty before becoming a
professor of law she taught at Wisconsin
School of Law at the City University of
New York law school and Golden Gate
University School of Law she joined the
faculty of Columbia Law in 1991
she's been honored with fellowships at
Dartmouth College and at the center for
the Advanced Study in the behavioral
sciences at Stanford and she is a
MacArthur Fellow as well professor
Williams has been a prolific and
tireless writer on issues of race gender
the law and social justice as well as on
legal theory her many books include the
alchemy of race and rites 1992 the
roosters egg on the persistence of
prejudice 1997 seeing a colorblind
future the paradox of race in 1998 and
open house of family friends food piano
lessons and the search for a room of my
own
in 2005 which skip gates himself called
a seductive meditation on the personal
and political from one of the great
theorists of race and law in addition to
her books
Williams trenchant writing is regularly
and happily to be encountered in her
diary of a mad law professor for the
nation and her mad law professors blog
and she's frequently cited when they are
getting it right in the New York Times
The Washington Post Newsweek and
elsewhere the very first sentence of her
first book announced that a unique
sensibility had arrived on the scene
since subject position is everything in
my analysis of law she wrote you deserve
to know that it is a bad morning bad we
find out because Williams job as a
lawyer is now requiring her to wade
through in 1835 Louisiana case on record
voice that is defective merchandise
involving a defective slave named Kate
bad too because all the news is so bad
AIDS is spreading amid of an
indifference greenhouse gas has just
become a worry inequalities and
disparities of all sorts are widening
racialized violence punctuated the
nightly news and the carceral state has
come looming out of the swamp and bad
too because the macneil-lehrer report
has just reported Harvard Law School
Dean's contention that to hire even one
black woman professor would require
lowering Harvard standards beginning
with this bad morning in about 1989 and
ever since Patricia Williams has woven
these strands the racialized and
gendered nature of American law
contemporary social conditions as
reflected in our daily headlines the
racialized nature of our legal
institutions and the contention that
subject position is everything into a
tapestry of critique that is damning
unsparing compelling and yet also
strangely hopeful in its power to
illuminate in its wit
in its elegance in its originality and
creativity if she can do this on a bad
morning she provoked a whole generation
to suppose then the world isn't merely
bleak she also provoked a generation of
legal practitioners and scholars to
think differently about how the law is
embedded in history and a generation of
students and professors across the
humanities and social social sciences to
think differently about how history is
embedded in the law now I can't resist
telling you a few days ago a colleague
of mine saw me carrying a copy of the
alchemy of race and rights and said oh
my god when I was in grad school
we passed that book around like a joint
Williams career as a public voice runs
basically from the Rodney King beating
and the Thomas Hill hearings to this
season of Michael Brown John Crawford
Tamir rice Eric garner Walter Scott and
Eric Harris here's just a paragraph that
has been haunting me from her recent
writing August brought us John Crawford
jr. Crawford was shopping at a Walmart
in Beavercreek Ohio when he picked up
when he picked from the shelf an airsoft
rifle that was for sale he continued
shopping gambling through the aisles
while talking with his wife on a cell
phone someone called the police to say a
man was waving a gun at women and babies
police arrived and quickly shot Crawford
in the back a grand jury found his death
a justified use of force although video
cameras recorded Crawford's motions
showing definitively that he never waved
the gun around never pointed it at
anyone never moved sharply or hastily
and that other shoppers seemed to be
calmly pursuing their business all
around him with no fear or aversion it
was according to prosecutor mark pipe
Meyer just a perfect storm of
circumstances a tragedy a tragic case
with no bad guys Williams continues I
suppose it is too easy to note that
Crawford was black surely there are
other observations such as it is insane
that toy guns are made to look like real
ones or it is insane that walmart sells
real guns as well as toy ones both ever
so casually located somewhere between
bedding and paper towels or it is insane
that after a nine-year-old girl killed
her instructor while trying to operate
an Uzi and Uzi at an event in Colorado
neither her parents nor the gun range
were held criminally responsible
I do not posit these reflections to
underscore the power of racial
stereotypes she wrote Ferguson is also
about the vivid yet deadly
hallucinations that have led us into
full-blown
war with ourselves deadly hallucinations
that have led us into full-blown war
with ourselves and that's the thing
that's been haunting me for the while
since I read this piece from the Rodney
King beating onward for 20 years and
more we have needed Williams voice and
her insight tonight at what still feels
a precarious moment we are very lucky
indeed to welcome Patricia Williams to
Yale for the annual Henry Louis Gates Jr
lecture
thank you so so much for that incredibly
generous and kind introduction I'm very
indebted to you it's a pleasure to be
here and thank you mr. rose for your
sponsorship of this appearance again it
is my pleasure and my honor at war with
ourselves I am really struck by the news
of just within the last few days the
report a leaked report apparently from
the Missouri National Guard shows that
protestors were referred to as enemy
forces and the militarization of that
language bides with me at this moment
and then today this morning the front of
today's New York Times features a story
calculating that approximately one and a
half million black men are absent from
daily life in the United States mostly
through early death or incarceration and
this has apparently resulted in a
lifelong gender gap that is not found
among white Americans these men are
missing as the article puts it in effect
they have disappeared from view
absent invisible unwarned making them
appear or reappears of course why
hashtag black lives matter is so
important as is excavating the hole this
leaves not only in the lives of black
women which seem to be a major focus of
this piece not only the hole they leave
in the lives of black families and
children but in our polity among white
citizens and in the world at large so
how do we bring them into view envision
what is our perpetual erasure of them
and the inadequately effort of such
eternal return we have been dusting off
all our anthropological microscopes and
telescopes and social lenses and
polishing our binoculars trying to bring
each other into focus particularly since
Ferguson
and it's a moment filled with a kind of
new faith and cameras as granting us
moral transparency particularly in the
area of law enforcement if we see it we
will know it of course
this new faith requires old skills of
perhaps film theory and criticism in
order to understand what there is to be
seen first let me say that I really do
think it is a good idea cameras on
police dashboards wearable cameras on
police officers it has also been
suggested that citizens particularly
black citizens should armed themselves
with little cameras embedded in their
clothing Google glasses and Google hats
and Google t-shirts tracking themselves
as they live their lives quietly
ceaselessly in a ritual of Perpetual
exoneration like performance art quietly
ceaselessly black men should be tracked
so as to mind the ex post facto
transmission of agency as in the killing
of Walter Scott the theatre of that
death in North Charleston North Carolina
began a South Carolina sorry began with
a litany like so many before it it began
with a chant we know by heart a prayer
we can say together
he reached for my weapon a struggle
ensued I feared for my life the weapon
discharged Amen what most of us would
now call the reality of Scott's death
was provided by a passerby with a quite
good long-range lens on his cell phone a
counter narrative of the subaltern one
we knew before we knew a memory
remembered a recall in response he was
running away he was shot in the back he
was unarmed the weapon was planted
repeat this course at the end of every
verse now of course we know that seeing
doesn't guarantee the scene
we know the empiricism of digital
recording is not the same as resolving
whatever it propor
to show we have cameras on street
corners cameras and schools we have
cameras on subways in prisons libraries
and outer space and on the back of every
dollar bill we have our destiny engraved
the all-seeing eye of providence upon us
all the time we see Rodney King being
beaten we see Tamir rice being shot we
see Eric garner being strangled we do
see and we see what we want to see and
so today I thought I'd tell you eight
short stories eight quick stories of the
obvious the occluded impaired vision
scrambled imagery socio visual agnosia
belated recognition and regret I made up
that term socio visual agnosia in case
you were wondering there is an actual
neurological condition called visual
agnosia and if you've ever read Oliver
Sacks is the man who mistook his wife
her hat the patient in that eponymously
titled sa suffered from visual agnosia
an inability to recognize objects or
faces or to identify a thing by its
shape it's not really a vision problem
at all it's a neural disorder of
perception impairing the ability to
attach proper meanings or to interpret
or recognize what is seen so I'm taking
a bit of Liberty here but I find it
helpful to deploy it as a metaphor as a
cultural malady as well a hermeneutic
disease if you will an afflictive
affliction an affective affliction a
kind of warped circuitry in the
adaptational translation transaction
between self and surroundings and so my
first story is about the man who mistook
his gun for a Taser Robert Bates is of
course the 73 year-old insurance agent
whose best friend is Stanley glance the
sheriff of Tel
the County Bates has contributed
thousands of dollars to the department
over the years including vacations for
the top brass police vehicles and the
surveillance equipment used by the drug
task force in Tulsa it seemed I guess
only polite to invite him along to test
these goodies out now this is an
exercise some call pay-to-play
cash-strapped government offices
appreciate their major donors public
offices providing necessary public
services are grateful to citizens with
deep pockets who step up to the plate in
these hard times
who would begrudge a small return a
gratitude of favors small things like
ride-alongs and prison tours so donation
is probably not the right word
it is often just a little more offer an
acceptance tip for rat-a-tat-tat it more
resembles contract a benignly homegrown
version of disaster touring and so when
an unarmed black man named eric harris
tried to make a run for it during a
thoroughly bungled sting Robert Bates
thrill-seeking insurance agent volunteer
hanger-on who was not trained as an
officer who had never gone through
police academy although he had appeared
on cops reached for his taser and pulled
out his gun no I am sure it was an
accident I am sure it was the worst day
of his life as he professed I shot him
said Bates in pure surprise
I am sorry said Bates it was the worst
day of his life
no pay-to-play has quite a genealogy
some decades ago Joe Hodge then governor
of the Texas Board of Corrections he is
to invite his pals down to the prison
and engage in what was a long-standing
tradition among officials to wit a
staged hunt of inmates ostensibly as
part of an exercise to Train
tracking
Hadj and his friends would enjoy a nice
leisurely lunch while an inmate called
the dog boy was given a head start of a
few hours to criss cross eight square
miles of the prison compound then the
party of official guests mounted horses
assembled eight or nine dogs and rode
off after the designated escapee after
the exercise there was a sumptuous
barbecue and participants received
jackets embroidered with the words the
ultimate hunt mr. Hodge defended the
practice saying it was a prestigious job
for prisoners and indeed of recent
parolee was quoted as describing the
chase as a blast it was like I was free
I sure did like that after being inside
that building for so long in addition he
was offered a reduction of his sentence
again pay-to-play
is framed as contract a something for
something in this instance temporary
freedom and perhaps quicker ultimate
release in exchange for becoming the
quarry for dogs from the perspective of
the prisoner and for the gentleman
hunters they they went away well-fed
with a good story about hounds and
horses and again to top it off that gift
a souvenir the cowboy jacket upon the
back of which had been embroidered that
very catchy coda the ultimate hunt the
ultimate hunt it anticipates it hungers
for it so wants for a reality show to go
with it could have should have been
perhaps it is as though to fill in that
subjunctive mood that were recently
Arizona's sheriff joe arpaio offered
actor steven seagal a tank an actual
tank my kingdom for a tank with which to
break up a coven of animal cruelty a
conspiracy of [ __ ] fighters a dangerous
den of rioting roosters the original
cage fighters right there in Maricopa
County Sheriff up high
Arpaio needed good publicity it seems
and Steven Seagal had a reality show
and a TV crew at hand which filmed him
driving said tank along with a SWAT team
and a bomb robot through the front wall
of the poultry harbouring residence
crushing to death the family's new puppy
the warrior birds were taken into
custody and killed now you may have
heard about this incident because there
was so much discussion about whether
killing the puppy was absolutely
necessary and killing the [ __ ] to save
them from cruelty Lent irony to the
endeavor it is a quandary sometimes how
to save the animals from themselves and
so you may have heard also about the
story more recently of Korey Knowlton a
man who won an auction at the Dallas
Safari Club and he paid 350 thousand
dollars for the privilege of shooting a
black rhino a species close to
extinction magnificent creatures whose
numbers whose numbers are below I
believe 2000 and mr. Knowlton explains
that he is actually helping their
survival because he plans to KO only an
older cranky bull giving younger black
ground rhino males the chance to rise to
the top of the hierarchy of aggression
it's the circle of life plus the money
goes to the government of Namibia which
needs it to pay its Park Rangers to
protect against poachers which mr. Noles
Nolton most emphatically is not for that
would be the circular thinking of life
the US Fish and Wildlife Service plans
to make an exception to its rules
against importation of endangered
wildlife they will permit him to import
the carcass as a trophy
given his great contribution to the
greater good meanwhile back in Texas
wild hogs are far from going extinct
apparently rather there is an
overpopulation of them as you may have
heard at least as asserted by many
farmers over whose land they roam
and in another act of public-spirited
volunteerism and pay-to-play singer ted
nugent saved the day
nugent enjoys apparently machine-gunning
hogs as he expressed it pigs turned me
on so armed with a helicopter and a
machine gun I believe it was last week
of the week before he flew over a range
spraying a wide arc of bullets down upon
the ground in one swooping rain of
firepower
he killed 455 of the varmints he had
quite a good time apparently since he
conducted the hunt live on Sirius radio
and dedicated the kill to Bill Maher and
quote other animal rights freaks now it
should be noted that there is a law in
Texas against aerial hunting but in an
efficient economy of public private
exchange Nugent's sorty has not been
considered sports hunting but rather
recast for purposes of the law as
population control where do these ideas
come from
we're aware aware Story number two in
2011 Sheriff Joe Arpaio in his endless
hunt for migrant laborers launched what
he called an air posse and as the word
posse implies it was made up of 30
private planes stuffed by quote citizen
vigilantes and deputies from human
smuggling and drug enforcement units all
of them armed with m16s and a 50 caliber
machine gun according to Arpaio we're
going to use our automatic weapons if we
have to and I'm tired of my deputies
having to chase these people and I'm
sure the air posse will be able to spot
these guys running as they constantly do
from us now also reported on serious and
beyond reporters in Texas have been
describing crowds of citizens calling
for the immediate deportation of
unaccompanied minors fleeing across the
from Guatemala El Salvador and Honduras
they fear the children some as young as
six as disease varying parasitic upon
tax dollars and criminally inclined not
our children not our problem reads a
sign one woman holds and radically
scattered elements drift to mind in no
particular chronological order yet
suddenly linked a photo I saw years ago
of a classroom in Guatemala barefoot
Berta chalkboard on one of the walls the
village in which was located was so
war-torn families fleeing from
place-to-place that the determined
children who could make it to school
would bring their own chairs and
sometimes their own weapons from
wherever was home each day
I wonder yet farther back in time to the
1940s when the United States government
conducted non-consensual experiments
upon hundreds of Guatemalan prostitutes
prisoners and mental patients injecting
them with syphilis and gonorrhea just to
see what would happen
chickens coming home to roost is an
aphorism of which my grandmother was
extremely fond and she always used it to
describe the legacy of slavery the way
in which children are born full of light
and joy but when old enough to be turned
out to work the fields they come back at
the end of the day with a dark kind of
cruelty lurking behind their eyes and my
thoughts meander in a different
direction direction to recent
revelations about the Blackwater guards
finally condemned to a prison sentence
who for they're gunning down seventeen
innocent civilians in Baghdad in two
thousand seven weeks before that
incident many have forgotten that this
was a really a tragic turning point in
the supposed quest for Iraqi hearts and
minds but weeks before that shooting the
State Department had launched an
investigation into the
degree of criminality and chaos through
which Blackwater was already allegedly
responsible and that investigation was
actually blockaded outright Blackwater
spokesman in Iraq told the State
Department sleeving
lead investigator that he should watch
himself for he could kill him at this
very moment and no one could or would do
anything about it
and immediately thereafter the
investigator from the State Department
was ordered home for disrupting the
American Embassy's relationship not with
Iraq but with Blackwater I think two of
the violent breach of medical and
military ethics in our governments
attempted deploy of doctors to monitor
the administration of torture in
Guantanamo Bay and my scattered thoughts
roll on to the general public health
emergency of our failed health system
such that forty to sixty percent of
those who land in our jails or prisons
are suffering from untreated mental
illness I think of the National gun
lobby that tenaciously holds background
checks on refuses to hold background
checks of any sort and calls that its
own definition of insanity and I think
of Abu Ghraib and Charles greener
Charles greener is a free man since 2011
after serving six years of a ten year
sentence and he was also well known well
before he stacked prisoners into
pyramids or attached electrodes to their
testicles or beat them to death or gave
the thumbs up over their corpses Graner
before he left her rack had been a
prison guard in Pennsylvania and there
he'd been accused of abuse on many
occasions including an incident in 1998
where according to the Washington Post
Greiner and three other guards put a
razor blade in a prisoner's food and
then Greiner allegedly beat the prisoner
before getting into the hospital telling
him to shut up [ __ ] before we kill you
although a federal magistrate rules that
the case had arguable merit
in fact in law it was dismissed when the
prisoner was released and then like so
many others disappeared this takes me to
my next story about Rikers Island where
so many of those arrested under the
NYPD's so-called stop and frisk policy
of targeting those who commit very minor
infractions end up Rikers is a holding
facility not a prison meaning that the
vast majority of those at Rikers are not
convicts but only awaiting arraignment
or trial or if convicted have received
sentences no longer than a year yet
Rikers inmates suffer staggering and
disproportionate rates of serious
beatings requiring hospitalization and
other abuse the use of force having more
than doubled in the last five years the
New York Times did a phenomenal
excavation of this reality and the
impunity with which these beatings has
taken place is beyond doubt for many of
the salts have been captured on camera
in surveillance videos although even
that is exacerbated by guards removing
inmates from areas that have
surveillance cameras in order to beat
them in the medical unit often in the
presence of distressed medical stuff
apparently medical union's units do not
have cameras to protect privacy so
according to this four-month
investigation that the New York Times
did it has been quote common practice
normalized brutality for beatings to go
on at the clinic because of the lack of
cameras and despite thorough
documentation by the city's Department
of Health and Mental Hygiene by the
board of Corrections by the Department
of Corrections by the Health Department
by the office of the medical examiner
the New York Times and the mayor's
office there have been no prosecutions
to date of which I am aware said the
Bronx District Attorney's Office some of
these cases from Rikers Island in
particular some of the witnesses they
disappear they scatter
of course there were lots of witnesses
to the July death of Eric garner he was
killed after police throughout and
throttled him and this was ruled a
homicide I used that word advisedly
after police throttled him because they
thought he was selling loosies without a
license and a cell phone video of the
confrontation while going viral was
really intriguing not simply because of
the use of the long band technique
called a chokehold the sad politics of
that we are all familiar with what I was
most struck at was the behavior of the
emergency medical technicians who stood
alongside police and did nothing
idly peering down at him as he lay
unconscious watching him die
administering neither CPR nor
defibrillation even as God gathered
onlookers shouted at them to do so now
according to a National comorbidity
study and the National Institutes of
Health approximately 3.5 percent of the
American population suffer from
post-traumatic stress disorder about 14
percent of New York City firefighters
have PTSD as well as 20% of Iraqi War
veterans
31 percent of prison guards in more than
half of all prison inmates and according
to a study by the safer foundation up to
68 percent of incarcerated women
my next story is a story about our
having gotten to the point that not
shooting seems to have become remarkable
again just last week a man suspected of
murder and suffering from mental illness
but unarmed threw himself at police
officers shouting shoot me shoot me
the policeman did not shoot him and as
recorded by the officers camera the man
was unbalanced but capable of being
subdued and he was subdued handcuffed
and carted away yet if you remember much
of the press congratulating the police
officer in language that I found
troubling they praised him not for
keeping his cool or for assessing the
situation and acting appropriately
rather it was repeatedly asked described
as a suicide-by-cop attempt and that the
police officer didn't fall for it as
though the police's task were to fight
against the passive inevitability of
being the instrumentality of the
subjects will a hero this police officer
was described for resisting the
invitation to shoot the man he didn't
let the suspect turn his hand into a
lethal weapon he refused to let the
suspect rest bullets from his gun he
didn't obey when the suspect ordered him
to kill and the agency here is weird and
I think of it as I tend to call it the
ventriloquism of the passive voice the
passive voice is used to bury the agency
and to reassign responsibilities as
sometimes in these situations the active
voice is used to animate the passive but
this is a species of puppetry that
puppetry that short-circuits painful yet
crucial opportunities to reflect upon
the complexities of power and its
absolutes and I worry we have dulled our
responses to the sharp moral questions
we might otherwise
have to confront in recent years again
an increasingly increasing number of
such confrontations are called police
assisted suicide or against suicide by
cop
and this unfortunate terminology shifts
agency away from a public officer who
justifiably or not actually makes the
decision to fire his weapon it read
ascribes the police as passive
extensions of the outlandish will of the
deceased by law police actions are
constrained by the reasonable exercise
of force but why bother with all that if
dying was by the crazy person's choice
rather than at the officers hand it is
the sort of shifted responsibility you
used to hear in fiction that used to
come out of the Wild West the frontier
West when people some people would say
he needed killin it used to be that kind
of cliche common perhaps as a
regionalism of the south used as a
cipher for vigilante justice it referred
casually to extra legal justice or an
impassioned response to a particularly
heinous crime it meant that someone or
maybe a group of vigilantes took it upon
themselves to do away with a dastardly
criminal without due process without
benefit of jury without benefit of doubt
or appeal because it is a mark that does
not have the right to have rights as
political scientists Margaret Summers
might put it now this is also pay to
play and a consequence of narrow
cost-benefit thinking is that the
exchange not only is deadly
but cheapens us the polity the state
I've written before about the serial
killer in the Bay Area a man who
strangled his victims and convicted and
sentenced to death he begged the state
to hang him he apparently got as much
erotic pleasure from strangulation as
Ted Nugent gets from machine gunning
what a peculiar moral lens we are left
with if we view executions as choice as
preference when we over endow prisoners
with an autonomy far beyond the
constricted options of the very
circumstance or of imprisonment and
simultaneously under endow the state
with responsibility for the fate of
those within its sphere of life and
death control without such a commitment
we will have really eviscerated the
meaning of habeas corpus it is the
responsibility of police to use least
force possible to deescalate passions
not inflame them to distinguish among
guilty and innocent adult and distressed
it is not an easy job particularly in a
society as well armed as ours
but it points to the necessity of a
politics that is beyond cost-cutting or
carelessly probabilistic profiling or
throwing bigger and better weapons at an
already inflamed social setting and
there is a terrible familiarity a
repetition to these crises the
incoherent policies of bunkering and
quarantine the criminalization of whole
populations the militarized purported
necessity of human degradation the
bloody splashing repercussion of
retributive justice and so the witnesses
scatter the chickens come home to roost
and I remain curious about the explosive
histories that sent those chickens
flying into distant disorder but that we
assign to oblivion as they now now glide
back to earth like embers and ashes the
regrouping phoenixes of reiterated to
traumas I'm left with an ominous vision
of flocks of mean-spirited birds
broken-winged and brooding gathering in
unnatural silence as though before a
storm
my next to the last story number seven
and this was actually the subject of a
column I did for those of you who read
my column about going out to dinner in
Manhattan to a nice little Japanese
restaurant on the Upper West Side and
around 5:30 in the afternoon the place
was filled with mothers and fathers
after school kids with their books
spread out of me amid this platters of
sushi and right in the middle of the
miso soup course the place was robbed
and too skinny teenagers probably no
more than 15 years old had come in and
when the waitress turned her back seized
the cashbox and fled with five staff
members pounding after them to no avail
it was very sudden it was very unnerving
and I was left with a kind of fairy tale
lack of resolution fists were shaken no
one died life continued shaken but not
substantially stirred and police weren't
even called because it's New York
and because the maitre d explained with
a shrug that there wasn't a lot of cash
is a mostly credit card of establishment
and in the truly only in New York form
people went back to their meals and
children went back to their homework and
the place resumed the murmurs of
conversation and clinking crockery and
next to me there was an understandably
distressed mother she was at a table in
the throes of the adrenaline everyone in
the establishment was suffering and she
lashed out at those horrible people but
the longer she went on the more it
became clear that the plural as she used
it was broader than this just the two
kids who had come and gone her
indictment of those and of people was of
some vastly expanding plural some big
bang repercussion of universal
horribleness the object of whom extend
far beyond the to extended far beyond
the two skinny kids who ran off with the
till but that wasn't the hard part the
hard part was listening to her child for
therein lies the hinge of the next
generation this child of only five or
six began to muse aloud about what he'd
do to bad guys if he ever caught them
the little boys piping voice carried
well as he really was quite gleefully
as little kids do imagining all the
things he'd do if he ever caught the
robber or a robber and it was vivid and
astonishingly graphic I assume he picked
it up from video games but honestly his
little rant reminded me nothing so much
as two cultural influences first the
kind that little girls are subject to
who are already so conflicted about
their body image that the first thing
they do with the Barbie doll is cut off
her hair and then snap off her head the
second cultural reference that came to
mind was that of our great and iconic
jurist the right honourable William
Blackstone who was so eloquent on the
subject of drawing and quartering from
his 18th century commentaries he
described drawing which means putting on
a rack and stretching the bodies of all
the joints are dismembered and then
quartering which requires that the body
be sawed into at least four pieces and
that then the forgotten parts of the
ritual isn't draining the blood
splitting heads putting heads on spikes
and so forth anyway the sound and the
fury and the details that this child of
this child imagined tactics of tore
terror of torture had a resonance that
seemed delivered across centuries and so
it was that it stayed with me awhile and
it stayed with me while I finished my
meal and then walked up the street two
blocks to a book party for Nell
Bernstein and her new book burning down
the house and her book is about juvenile
detention in the United States where
children and young teens are thrown into
prisons and become the objects of all of
that little boys elaborate fantasies
though that little boy wasn't old enough
to imagine the degree of sexual assault
in real juvenile facilities he hasn't
yet imagined all the details like the
kids sent to solitary for months at a
time or kneeling on glass for 12 hours
at a time or if they soil themselves
they have to clean it up themselves
afterwards as a general ethic of
violence and torture in general and in
juvenile prisons by and large that
little boy in the restaurant had pretty
much inhaled the cultural narrative of
racial racialized punishment danger
dehumanization and the need to make
these horrible people
as his mother put it disappear and as I
sat at this party and listened to Nell
Bernstein and realized that she was
recounting exactly what this little boy
and the restaurant had dreamed of doing
to those people I reflected upon the
fact that these are real bodies upon
whom that retribution is is enacted from
whom the imagined price is paid these
are real children who are the children
of the nannies that abound all over
Manhattan they are children who've grown
up in foster care or who have emotional
problems of themselves been victim of
crimes they are abused kids kids who've
been raped and trafficked but sometimes
they are just kids who haven't done much
of anything wrong their kids from
so-called million-dollar blocks for
police concentrate all their superpowers
their kids with arrest warrants issued
for riding bikes on sidewalks or having
a dusting of marijuana on their person
those whose scuffles as Nell Bernstein
puts it on the basketball court lead not
to being benched but rather to a month's
worth of solitary confinement they are
miscreants mischief makers children with
special needs one of the women at the
book party asked an astonishment isn't
this illegal what guards do to kids
who've been locked up and now responded
of course and when those kids who were
in there were having a joint get beaten
up and raped by their keepers they
learned that it really isn't about what
they have done it's all about who they
are so who are they what is going on in
our heads and I'll end with my eighth
story the story I call the woman who
fell from the sky and this is a story
about stories it's about the degree to
which race is an overwhelmingly
capacious proxy for narratives of
intellect
and criminality and sexuality and
economics and health and geography free
will fear of failure and the will to
keep on going it is a multi light story
that I pose in juxtaposition to the
story with which I began of the million
and a half black men who have
disappeared even though this is about
the body of a woman a woman who
committed suicide by leaping out a
window with her 10 month old baby
strapped strapped to her chest in one of
those snuggly little baby bjorn type
carriers and the first story I read was
this headline in the New York Post baby
survives Harlem mother's death leap
because you can always rely on the New
York Post for honest concision there is
just so much packed into those few words
now just the word Harlem instantly
shapes assumptions about what happened
she must be black desperately poor a bad
mother probably on drugs nuff said end
of story
and you can imagine the online
commentary to precisely that effect the
next day however the New York Daily News
coming a little late to the story ran
the report on its website under this
headline Manhattan mother jumps eight
stories to her death with her infant son
strapped to her chest baby survives with
minor injuries
with Manhattan as the modifier this
mother was more likely to be seen in
online commentary as white and as
selfish as desperately ambitious and not
on enough drugs for what was assumed to
be postpartum depression now as it
turned out this mother was also an
employee of the Manhattan State Supreme
Court and a graduate of Columbia Law
School
of course there was a stereotyped
narrative for that as well
glenn beck's news site the blaze
reported the story as lawyer mother
leaps from eight story building and
commentary from readers was peppered
with surmise about whether the woman was
a feminazi with a liberal death wish and
with relief that there was one less
lawyer in the world and finally three
days later there was this headline which
straddled the question of identity was a
bit of ambiguity
sources say Harlem lawyer Cynthia Walken
Haim penned a 13-page handwritten
suicide note before jumping out of an
eight-story window taking her son Kesten
with her the baby was saved from the
impact when the woman landed on her back
on the pavement and commentators were
pretty confused about this one harlem
lawyer lost named Walken Hine son with a
funny Ebonics sounding name like Kesten
and they were quite enraged
anyway I saved all of the headlines
about this incident and there were more
and turns them into this PowerPoint that
I shared at a conference not long ago
and an audience member remarked that she
was just blown away by the story she
said that it was beyond tragic such a
terrible mystery as to why all these
women were jumping off buildings with
babies strapped to their chests to say
nothing of the fact that all the babies
survived every single time anyway I tell
you all of this because I am so
intrigued by the kinds of progression
that these headlines reproduce there was
just to reassure you only one woman
jumping out of her 8th floor window yet
eight levels of degradation eight
stories of dying this mother falling
over
and over through multiply headlined
categories of being descending through
multiple ontological layers to her
inescapable doom
Cynthia Walken Haim Harlem I'd and
Manhattan I'd accomplished lawyer and
Columbia Law School graduate depressed
wife and bad mother became a floating
signifier in death more than one being
in our cultural narrative torn into
pieces by powerfully loaded descriptors
in the mouths of others and I wish there
were some kind of bum in writing about
the pain of that incident I so so wish I
could will into being another ending but
this is not an easy world we live in
very vexed times on an exhausted planet
where more and more are and will be
subject if you were in fewer of life's
necessities like clean water air enough
to eat
shelter and kindness it is sometimes
very hard to find the inspiration and
resilience necessary to expand and
contract in the face of all these
dismembering social forces and I was
very moved at lunch as many of you
students and faculty spoke of the
university as a place to think in
collective ways about our collective
problems about not losing ourselves
about providing stewardship about
knowing that the world will be a cruel
run at times so hurting ourselves as the
airlines tell us by donning our
parachutes putting on your oxygen masks
putting on stilts to rise above it all
donning our high-heeled running sneakers
and emotional sponges crash helmets and
pillowed landing gear so when challenged
by walls when thrown off cliffs we can
learn to become spider-man and Wonder
Woman prepared as well as gifted with
supernatural powers
we so need these gathered powers of
thought
we must continue to provide the cushions
from full-body blows the softer landings
the gentler understandings weaving the
safety net that will sustain all of us
our babies our boys our girls our
parents our politicians and our police
so that they might all face this world
with resilience and kindness and when
thrown for a loop or from a great height
we might bounce back up unbroken and
carry on